je pose la question où est passé ma
chemise
je suis pressé je t'ai dit que je
partais à une réunion ce matin il y a
des embouteillages il faut que je parte
tout de suite alors si j'ai pas de
chemise propre je peux pas aller à mes
réunion je peux pas y aller encore
rouler
tu viennes me parler à moi de tes
chemises mais ça me paraît vraiment
quelque chose de complètement
surréaliste c'est pas surréaliste enfin
je te parle de quelque chose de
d'élémentaire je crois que si je vais
travailler il faut quand même que j'ai
une chemise à mettre de ta chemise enfin
comment as-tu fait on s'est marié tu as
les 36 ans pour tes cheveux
exploiter
au moins leur femme s'occupe de leur
exploiter en quoi les hommes et les
femmes travaillent dehors ils
travaillent dedans qu'il partage le
travail à l'extérieur qui est un travail
payé et reconnu et qui n'est pas oui je
veux changer les mœurs et je suis pas la
seule à vouloir changer les mœurs les
mœurs ne changent pas avec des lois
sociales les mœurs se changent avec un
changement des mentalités mais pour que
les mentalités changent il faut aussi
qu'il y a un changement de loi
enfin toujours est-il que je n'ai pas ma
chemise